cartha d dick deloach author of
hoover's fbi the inside story of
hoover's trusted lieutenant
why did you write the book
brian i felt like i had to
either me or
one of ten thousand other ex-agents of
the fbi are current agents of the fbi
but mostly agents of that particular era
there have been so many distortions of
history
ludicrous yellow journalism to the fact
that people wanted to make a fast buck
out of
uh by spreading uh arrogant rumors of
rumors were totally false innuendo
which you'll find throughout the book in
which i combat
uh
i wanted the book to be believable to
have believability so consequently i
indicated our faults and j edgar
hoover's faults but the book had to be
written so that i feel that my children
my and my grandchildren other people's
children and grandchildren
can go to the college and university
libraries and find something besides
garbage on the shelves concerning the
fbi of our urine about j edgar hoover
let me jump to the end
you have a chapter in which you tell the
story of mr hoover's last day when he
died when was that
that was
1972. i believe it was march 2nd 1972 if
i'm not mistaken in his job then his job
was director of the fbi he died in the
job how old was he he was 78 years of
age in the job in the job
where were you that day i was uh
in indianapolis indiana presiding over a
meeting and i got a call from
dick klein deans who was attorney
general
and he swore me to secrecy and then
indicated that mr hoover had died
and uh i was shocked i was distressed
frankly i'd i he'd been in the job so
long and uh and i thought he was gonna
stay on it forever and as a matter of
fact he told me once i will never leave
this job and he never did
but klein dean said the attorney general
asked me to come back to washington and
take over the bureau
in an acting capacity until president
nixon could appoint me or someone else
i told him i would have to check with
the chairman of the board of pepsico
whom i was reporting to and working for
at the time as a vice president of
pepsico
and i also wanted to check my wife and
to think a little bit about it
and he said he knew it would be a
financial loss compared to my job in
private industry but that he would
appreciate it and so will the president
if i would come back and take over
i said well give me at least until 12
noon to give you an answer and he said
fine
and i called him back at 12 noon and he
indicated that
president nixon still wanted me but he
also wanted somebody else too but would
i come back just in an interim capacity
i told him no i would not do that
and
so that was about it
but on that day
that mr hoover died
he had a visitor who
you say
they had trouble knowing what to do with
who was that and why was she there
that was linda bird johnson and i knew
her well she was a good friend when her
father was in the white house
but she was there to interview j edgar
hoover about his two dogs karen terriers
and frankly the agents didn't know what
to do with her and finally one of them
did tell her
after the press release had gone out
from the white house
that hoover had died
she was shocked she rushed to the pond
and told her father and he was shocked
also
lbj was still living then at the lbj
ranch
in texas
she was
regarded by hoover as somewhat of a
foster daughter and as much as
she her mother father and her sister
lucy lived right across the street from
j edgar hoover on 30th place northwest
so as a result she found had somewhat of
a proprietary interest in her opinion to
to interview him occasionally and she
was doing it this time i believe for
good housekeeping
how long was he director of the fbi
from 1919 when he became acting director
he became director in
1924 until 1972
how long did you work for him almost 29
years
i almost thought i'd make a career of it
brian
what was the highest job you had
uh as his deputy
the formal title was assistant to the
director
but uh he called it deputy and uh at
times when he was out of town i act i
served as uh acting director of the fbi
one of the stories that you deal with is
that day that he died
that you say
an author made all kinds of suggestions
that uh
you can tell the story about
a body being removed from the house at a
time that he wasn't even dead yet what
was that whole story about that
had to do with
the
allegations
uh made by a number of individuals again
having no basis in fact whatsoever
allegations that the fbi had secret
files hidden away in in j edgar hoover's
house and he had taken them and placed
them there for safekeeping there were no
secret files in his house there were no
files whatsoever in his house concerning
the fbi
others felt that his body had been
placed in a blanket at seven o'clock in
the morning
and sent to the funeral home actually
his body had not even been discovered by
that time so again it was just false
allegations concerning secrets suppose
secret files and his body had been taken
away
in a clandestine manner which was
absolutely false as are many of the
allegations concerning him he had his
faults
and i'll be glad to tell you any of
those in my opinion
but nevertheless uh having secret files
at his home or having secret files
anywhere brian
the allegation has been made time and
time again that he had secret files for
the purposes of blackmailing members of
congress
that's totally preposterous
we had behind helen gandy's desk and
helen gandy was his secretary for over
45 years
we had
two file cabinets
and one of the file cabinets had two and
a half drawers of files
one some of those files concerned john f
kennedy eleanor roosevelt a concern a
under secretary of state who had
committed a homosexual act
and concerned
richard nixon and various other notables
now why why did we have them there
simply because of the fact that we
didn't want young gs2 clerks coming in
from the boondocks
and making a beeline right away for
those files
to satisfy their curiosity and then
possibly going out and advising mom or
dad or someone else i have had a chance
to look at the file of this great
personality so we would take the top
files of notables and take them and put
them behind helen gandy's desk they were
not secret files i could look at them
any any uh
individual on the top level in the fbi
could look at them if they had a
a
legitimate reason for doing so
but
they weren't secret files they were open
to all of us at all times and the only
reason we moved them was to keep prying
eyes from going out and gossiping
did fdr ask the bureau to investigate
his wife yes he did
he had information and i don't know from
where
but he asked who at that particular time
to put a surveillance on mrs roosevelt
for the purpose of determining whether
or not she was
having secret rendezvous with with a
certain
army colonel and with a state trooper in
new york
and we did that accordingly at the
instructions the president
which brings up to mind the fbi has been
used or misused
by many president and by attorneys
general
which the fbi is under
you say that uh an agent dressed up as a
milkman
yes
and and how what happened
well he asked
he went in the uh
the apartment where mrs roosevelt was
staying
and she was dressed in a house coat at
the time and
the individual at the president
roosevelt was somewhat suspicious i was
in the apartment at the time mrs
roosevelt was making him breakfast and
this was the only way that the agent
could determine whether or not she was
meeting with this individual
and he did get the proof and he put it
in the report and the report was given
to the president
do you ever get any sense of what the
president did with the information none
whatsoever and we could care less
frankly it was misusage of the fbi by a
president
and i think uh here again that
president roosevelt misused the fbi more
than any other president although they
have been used by most all presidents uh
since the beginning or since the
inception of the federal bureau of
investigation
did you say you caught a secretary of
state in a homosexual act no an
undersecretary of state under secretary
yes did you do you name we didn't catch
him
the report was given that the under
secretary of state's traveling to
senator
um keller's funeral in tennessee
uh had lured a porter
into a bunk bed uh
during that particular trip
and we were asked by the president to
investigate that matter and we did and
the report here again was turned over to
president roosevelt but the copy was
kept in fbi files
how did you decide what information to
put in this book
and did you i mean is there any
restriction on this kind of information
and how much of it is first time
i don't think there should be any
restriction on the information i put
the inside information concerning the
president's asking us to do various
things in there simply because of the
fact to prove there were no secret files
that was the basis for doing it in that
particular chapter
uh
whether the restrictions currently today
are not i don't know but when i left the
fbi
i took with me
only
the the matters that were pertaining to
me personally as a matter of information
but also
i requested the director of the fbi who
was
judge webster that particular time
to send me copies of every memorandum i
wrote between 1951 and 1970 particularly
had anything to do with the white house
or the congress and i received over six
thousand memoranda from the fbi under
the freedom of information act that was
the basis of considerable my information
and the rest came from
personal memories that i recall very
vividly
could others have asked for that same
information that the the the memorials
that you wrote or is it just you that
could ask for that
absolutely they could receive the same
thing that i received that they only
asked for
under the freedom of information act i
was given no favors in that regard
what did you think of j edgar hoover
he was a very complex man he was very
formal austere aloof
he was a perfectionist
he was probably the best public
relations a toe dancer in washington and
so far as
realizing the importance of something
and taking advantage of it
but by the same token i think that he
could very safely and very properly be
called the father of modern day law
enforcement why
because he himself
advocated and promoted the
centralization of fingerprinting by
usage of police all throughout the world
the free world that is he brought into
new standards
raising the standards rather of law
enforcement and giving
law enforcement officers something to be
proud of in handling their position
the national crime information center
which is a great boon
and a new initiative for law enforcement
has saved many lives
that is the recording of stolen goods
and stolen automobiles and stolen
jewelry and paintings
and the listening of fugitives
throughout the united states and many
other things the fbi laboratory the
training of police he brought all this
about it may not have been his idea to
start out with but nevertheless he
capitalized on it and brought it about
for usage for all of law enforcement and
it has helped
law enforcement considerably who's clyde
tolson clyde tolson was the associate
director of the fbi for
many of the latter years of hoover's
life clyde tolson was sick he had a
stroke he had
several other things that happened to
him
and he was ill quite a bit of the time
but in his heyday he was a very sharp
individual had a brilliant mind he could
handle administrative work or paperwork
faster than anyone i've ever seen where
is he in this picture
clyde tolson is uh on the top picture he
is uh this one right here the bottom one
he's standing in the bottom
he's sitting in the far end of the table
and that is the living quarters of the
president of the united states london b
johnson and you're off to the right next
to him that's correct and london johnson
has his back to it linda johnson had his
back to us
and how close was clyde tolson
to j edgar hoover
he was uh an ally
let me preface my remarks this way brian
please
um
every man needs a close friend
somebody he can trust somebody's loyal
to him whether it's his wife his son his
daughter hoover had no family after his
mother died so he needed a friend an
ally
and clyde tolson was that ally someone
he could trust now
the basic wrong in that
was clyde tolson showed slovish
disobedience to j edgar
slavish obedience to g edgar hoover when
he should at times disagreed with him
for the good of the organization but if
the boss meaning mr hoover said
something
clyde tolston said this is what we've
got to do i can remember many times
when the executive's conference voted
uh 11 to zero unanimously for a specific
matter
but it was sent into hoover and hoover
would say no i disagree
so tolson would call us back together
and said obviously we were wrong hoover
was remember the director was right and
therefore we've got to do it over again
there was slavish obedience there there
was loyalty to the core
and i think at times that uh tolson and
any of us maybe we would have lost our
jobs we would have lost the battle to
win a skirmish but i think tollson
should have showed uh disagreement at
times who is sid richardson and clint
murchison they were friends of hoover
they were multi-millionaires from texas
they owned the new york central railroad
for a time they owned many other things
particularly land in texas
they would go on vacations and hoover
would meet them at the del charo hotel
in san diego
he would also meet them in other places
they paid his bills from time to time
they paid his dinner bills they paid his
hotel bills from time to time
he thought that he was uh in
uncorruptable and in particular in his
later years
it was wrong for him to allow this to be
done but he knew in his own mind
that they were never asking for any
favors and they never did
uh they did not try to capitalize on the
fact that they had paid his bills
then it wasn't considered totally wrong
today in the day's life yes it is
but as director of the fbi that should
not have been done you have a whole
chapter in here devoted to
the gay director question mark why
simply because of fact i wanted to
combat the distortions of history
the ludicrous charges that have been
raised about the fact that j edgar
hoover was a homosexual and a
transvestite i live with a man as far as
being in having an office next door or
next to his for 15 years i travel with
him i've stayed in the same suite with
him on occasion
i was in his home he was in my home on
very infrequent occasions
i knew the man i knew he was not a
homosexual as did all of his people who
worked for him i knew that he was not a
transvestite
he was a deeply religious aloof formal
individual who was greatly uh
charged by the uh
by his uh rearing by his mother who was
a very formal uh deeply religious person
and well disciplined
um let me read you a statement that you
made in your book in that chapter he was
certainly more of a man than mr summers
and i've seen both at close quarters yes
what are you talking about
uh tony summers interviewed me for his
book
and he did not use use hardly any of the
proofs that i gave him or facts i gave
him concerning the fact that that uh j
edgar hoover's activities or the fbi's
activities
and uh
i think that and you know having known
mr hoover and being in his office almost
every day
uh particularly during the last 15 years
i was there
that i knew him very well and i thought
that i sensed
uh in summers uh what exactly what his
makeup was and
i think that hoover was much more of a
man than summers
what would have been wrong if he had
been a homosexual
in the light of the society
today the the society of that particular
day
back in the 60s and 70s here was a man
that was director of the fbi who was
charged with some of the gravest
security and espionage problems of the
nation
he would be totally subject to blackmail
and many other things if he had been a
homosexual or transvestite but let me
add to that brian
what what where's the proof that he was
a homosexual
uh summers and others have indicated
that there were pictures involved where
are the pictures
who are the sources one of his main
sources was an individual a woman in new
york who was a convicted percher an
inmate of rockers island prison
and who felt that her husband had gained
inside information from j edgar hoover
to gain a divorce from her in a messy
suit
hoover had not given rosenstein any
information or anyone else but that was
one of summer's main sources
other sources that he used some of them
were corpses
and i think the corpses were dug up
today they'd be astonished to find
they've been quoted in this particular
way
but nevertheless uh there's no proof
whatsoever that the man was a homosexual
or transvestite what could been wrong
with it only the fact that he would have
been subject to blackmail and have been
stigmatized uh accordingly as director
of the fbi
did you know abe fortis yes i knew him
well he was a good friend
i admired him and respected him
when he was an attorney
when he was lyndon johnson's attorney
and when he was on the supreme court
i thought he had a very keen mind
you tell stories though
about him in which you say he was
where it is and they're downright
unethical
when he was on the supreme court
what were you talking about
i don't say that he was unethical i said
that maybe he may have stretched the
line a little bit
in still remaining lbj's attorney even
though he was a justice of the supreme
court
but my association with him came about
in several different ways number one
the fact that uh
i felt that we felt uber and i both felt
and tolson that uh
that bobby kennedy was attempting to
give the the supreme court
uh possibly some false information in in
as much as and so far as
the usage of wiretaps and microphones
are concerned
also there came the time when
lyndon johnson wanted his pros
prospective son-in-law
chuck robb who's now a senator
investigated prior to the time that he
married linda bird
and he asked both justice portis and me
to handle that
brief investigation we did there was
nothing wrong with chuck robb nothing
derogatory in his background he had been
a distinguished
captain in the marine corps
but uh that was misusage of the fbi but
that was again was dealing with abe
fortis when he was a a justice
what i was referring to earlier about i
have to go this is these are your words
of course portis's involvement in the
matter was blatantly unethical and this
is that whole matter of bobby kennedy
and the bugs and and that
you ended up going up to the supreme
court when he was on the court and
meeting with him would you tell us more
about that
yes
i felt that
this was in the uh
black case the usage of uh electronic
surveillance and microphones in the
black case
and hoover felt at the time that uh
the department of justice
actually thurgood marshall who later
became a justice went up and argued the
case for the justice department
concerning black black had indicated
that the usage of his attorneys had
indicated the usage of microphones would
negate any decision made in his case
and thurgood marshall argued against
that and we were afraid that uh
not only would be would we be
stigmatized
if the department of justice did not
give out the correct facts which we
didn't think they would do
because they wanted to escape uh being
politicians they wanted to escape any
blame or stigmatization themselves but
we felt the court
uh would lean and lean over backward to
knock out all electronic surveillances
which we desperately needed this was a
lobbyist named fred black yes exactly
in what year do you remember i don't be
in the middle 60s somewhere i think
that's correct
marshall was solicitor general that's
correct or 63 64 i believe one of those
years but you ended up going up and
having a private meeting when there was
a case before the court now you say in
this in this uh chapter that mr fortis
justice fortis had
uh
recused himself he was not not involved
in this case that's correct but he still
did something in the he had an impact on
it he felt he had the right to give the
other justices the correct facts
as given to him
and i felt he had the right to do so
but uh would you want
people running in and out of that
supreme court talking to these justices
in these cases all the time like that
if they needed the correct facts yes
if we felt that they would not get the
correct facts that the fact would be
bent
for politicians to escape blame on any
particular cause they should they have
the right to the correct facts but isn't
that what briefs are for i mean the
private meetings
are supposed to be
not allowed that's very true that's very
true
but uh by the same token we were dealing
with facts and i gave the correct facts
to justice for us and he acted
accordingly what happened in the end
then
in this case
i don't recall the uh the outcome of the
decision to tell you did you get what
you wanted though yes
yes
the supreme court did not indicate that
uh
the investigative agency of the
government should do without electronic
surveillance
uh we saved that particular uh matter
for
further usage when necessary and when
approved by the attorney general
and uh insofar as the outcome of the
black case is concerned i don't i don't
recall
you write about an agent hosti in
the assassination of john f kennedy who
was he and what role did he play
agent hostie was a special agent
assigned to the dallas office of the fbi
when lee harvey oswald became involved
with a fair play
for cuba committee and was giving out
leaflets on the streets of new orleans
got in a fist fight with a bystander on
the street because he was favoring fidel
castro
then later moved to dallas agent hostie
was assigned the case involving lee
harvey oswald but more so his wife was a
was uh
not a naturalized citizen she had come
here from the soviet union
and he also uh in in in accordance with
our policy at that particular time we
were to interview citizens who came in
there people who came in here from the
soviet union
uh if they had not become citizens or
had no indication of becoming citizens
or showed no indication so as a result
he tried to get in touch with marina
oswald on several different occasions
agent hosty
was not present the day
that lee harvey oswald brought a note to
the dallas office of the fbi
the note in our opinion was not
threatening
but the note was given to agent hostie
later on he showed the special agent
charge
whose name was gordon shanklin shanklin
indicated that the note should be
destroyed
apostate states that
he followed the sacs the special agent
charges instructions
but
he too agreed that the note was not
threatening and he did destroy it
in retrospect he now states that he
didn't think that
that was a good idea that he should have
saved it
but he did say it was under his agent
charges instructions that had nothing to
do with the
indication that uh the president john f
kennedy was assassinated by lee harvey
oswald lee harvey oswald even though he
had been
sympathetic to the fair play for cuba
committee had been to mexico had been
the soviet union
was not considered a threat to the
president of the united states but was
not considered a threat to anyone he was
a milk toast to a great extent a loner
he'd been in the marine corps
he was a marksman in the marine corps
yes he'd been kicked out
then he went to the soviet union where
he met marina married her came back to
the states
but
he was despite all that he was not
considered a threat to anyone and under
our policies that particular time
we did not furnish the information
concerning lee harvey oswald to the
secret service we did many other
individuals in the dallas uh
area
uh at that at the time that
president kennedy was going there
but oswald was the agent assigned to
that particular matter
and oswald i think
while he should have brought the note to
the attention of the fbi but
fbi headquarters
nevertheless did not do so at the
instructions of his agent charge
as a result he was later disciplined as
were
other fbi personnel in the matter
you opened the book but with a champion
called hoover's
fbi
and this sentence messers jenkins
walter jenkins
moyers bill moyers of pbs
and
carter
i i don't know the name carter
he was an aide to the president at that
time president johnson were particularly
interested in suppressing dissent from
black groups
bill moyers interested in suppressing
dissent from black groups well the bill
moyers of then is not the dome warriors
of today bill moyers had
an assignment from president johnson to
control what went on at the democratic
national convention in 1964
and the rules committee of the democrats
at that particular time were especially
concerned concerning or regarding the
mississippi freedom democratic party
they wanted to be seated as delegates
rules committee voted that the regular
delegates who had been voted on in the
state were to be seated rather than the
mississippi freedom democratic party the
freedom democratic party came in and sat
in the seats of the regular delegates
moyers wanted them out of there maurice
wanted to control the situation
lawyers asked us
on his
radio and asked and asked his
transmitter
ask us to move the fbi to move these
delegates out of there we refuse to do
so
because i thought that was sheer
politics and i refused anything to do
with it
but
it was a different situation then
and he was acting under the orders of
the of the president
what was different about then and now
is not acting under the instructions of
lyndon b johnson today
warriors is acting in totally in a
different capacity without instructions
of that particular nature
you say you like president johnson i did
what did you see up close that you liked
and what did you see up close that you
didn't like
he was compassionate he would send
sausage at christmas time he would send
toys to my children
when my daughter had surgery in a
hospital in alexandria
he sent her flowers
he did many compassionate things and so
far as my family is concerned as a
matter of fact brian he uh on one
occasion the
easter
one year at easter time
asked my family and me to go to camp
david and stay there the entire weekend
and we did
on another occasion he was bombastic he
was he had a hot temper
uh even he would humiliate you if you
felt that you'd done something wrong or
something not to his liking
so but i liked him i like him as a man
then i like him now
i did not agree with his uh
policies and so far as legislation
involving finance is concerned or new
programs
but that was not up for me to decide i
was simply a liaison officer between the
fbi and president johnson
why did you call or why did the fbi
agents call the attorney general of the
united states ramsey clark bull
butterfly it wasn't the agents it was j
edgar hoover he just liked dealing with
ramsey clark he would had been good
friends with tom clark
but he felt that ramsay was somewhat of
a pipsqueak and uh rams tom clark's son
he felt that politics had put him in his
office when he didn't deserve to be
attorney general
and he felt that the best name he could
find for him was the bull butterfly and
he constantly in conversation with me
and other
viewer executives referred to him as a
bull butterfly
let me uh read you back some of the
words you used to describe j edgar
hoover
and ask you to explain what you meant by
them
fain
fame vane
vein
he was a man that had an ego
uh he was vain in
personality to some extent
uh he loved luxuries
uh he
would dress in satorial splendor to a
great extent
even though his surroundings his office
and his home
was not didn't express a splendor in the
lease was very common
but he himself personally uh wanted to
be uh
was very vain and wanting to dress the
best he could and
insisting that agents also have a proper
dress code
he was vain and so far his weight is
concerned
i recall one situation where he was
addressing to go to a state dinner at
the white house
and he found out that his trousers
wouldn't fit him that they were about
his waist had extended a couple of
inches and
so he had to
buy new trousers right away to go to
that state dinner but the following day
he put into order that all agents should
adhere to the metropolitan life
insurance standards concerning weight
now many agents
particularly pro football players or
college football players had
you know gained a little weight since
entering the fbi and they had a tough
time getting it off but the weight
control program
saved many lives and
i think it was a good thing regardless
three of us uh the top executives of the
fbi
one day he marched us down to the
nurse's quarters uh the the health room
on the fourth floor and he weighed us in
uh i weighed i was three pounds
overweight another person another
executive was
12 pounds overweight one was 10 pounds
overweight so he constantly dubbed us
the dreadnoughts and we were known that
for a long time but vanity was one of
his faults and i think he had a lot of
vanity you call him obsequious
yes
where did you see that
i felt that he was somewhat obsessed
in his uh
well let me put it this way
in the matter involving mrs claire
chanal
he gave me instructions not to follow
lyndon johnson's advice in writing
but he told clyde tolson to tell me to
go ahead and do it anyhow to obey
lyndon johnson's president johnson's
instructions
in so far as
obtaining toll calls
in albuquerque and new mexico
where the president thought richard
nixon had stopped on his campaign plane
actually it wasn't lyndon it wasn't
richard nixon it was uh
spiro agnew the vice presidential
candidate stopped in agony
here i had
one in writing
and uh telling me not to do it and
verbally telling me to do it i felt that
was somewhat obscure saying let me go
back though
that was 68 the campaign of 68. that's
correct lyndon johnson did not run in 68
hubert humphrey was the candidate
running against
richard nixon and lyndon johnson calls
you
or i think you said bromley smith calls
you who was working for lyndon johnson
and says what
he indicated that the president had
received information from the national
security agency indicating it
uh mrs chanal had been to the
uh south vietnam embassy who is mrs
chanel mr claire channel was the wife of
the flying tigers general claire chanal
and she was a strong republican
she socialized and she was very close
friends with john mitchell the attorney
general and was senator john tower
and she also liked and was friends with
the richard nixon
but that mrs chanal had been to the
south vietnamese embassy indicating it
it would be appreciated by certain
quarters if the
paris peace talks if the south
vietnamese would not go to the paris
peace talks
that infuriated president johnson who
was trying his best at that particular
time
to get the south vietnamese and the
north vietnamese together with the
united states that the parents peace
talks to close off the war
in uh in vietnam
and he was infuriated over the fact that
someone was trying to
meddle in that and in his opinion
and trying to
keep that from happening
the south vietnamese from being there so
that's why he requested the fbi through
bromley smith
at a time and later on he got into the
act personally himself but romney smith
asking the fbi on behalf of the
president to put a surveillance on mrs
chanal
and also to put a wiretap on mrs
chennault as well as the south
vietnamese embassy
we did so with the instructions of the
president and getting it in writing from
ramsey clark the attorney general who
was instructed by the white house to
give us approval to do that no at what
time in the campaign was that october
was that near this was after johnson had
indicated that he would not again seek
the
um
approval of his party for the candidacy
of president
he would not run again
and he put his strength behind hubert
humphrey but he wanted humphrey to
possibly get the credit
for closing off the vietnamese war
and of course the republicans wanted to
uh get credit for richard nixon for
doing it if the south vietnamese had not
gone to the paris peace talks and nixon
had already become president
then
he would get credit for possibly closing
off the war
uh so consequently it was a
it was a it's smacked of politics very
desperate very definitely one other
aspect that i want to ask you about
though at some point in the process fbi
agents moved into new mexico and
albuquerque and insisted to look at
telephone records
and whether or not there had been a call
place from albuquerque back to
mrs chanault or the south vietnamese
embassy from richard nixon's campaign
plan that's absolutely right but the
question i have for you is could fbi
agents even though this was a political
request
insist and see any telephone record in
the country at any time they wanted to
if they had the cooperation of the
telephone company in doing so yes and
that particular time they were not
seeking to play place a wiretap
on spiral agnew or richard nixon or
anyone else other than mrs chanel which
was done in the instructions of the
white house what they were seeking were
toll calls
and sparrow agnew's plane in albuquerque
rolled to a stop the phone was put on
board and five calls were made several
calls were made to new york one was made
to dean russ the secretary of state at
that particular time
there were no calls made to visit chanal
there were no calls made to the
south vietnamese embassy
but we did get the calls who they were
made to
what time they were made
and we turned that over to lyndon
johnson now let me go a step further
brian
one of the great
allegations that has been made which is
totally false
was that uh
the goldwater group at that particular
not the goldwater group the nixon group
at that particular time
indicated that
that
we were requested to put a microphone on
nixon's campaign plane by johnson
this never happened in the first place
it'd be almost a physical impossibility
for the plane being guarded at all times
and secondly even if you did place it on
board it would be almost a physical
impossibility to
to have it work properly considering the
unsophisticated usage of equipment at
that particular time so that's a false
allegation all it was were obtaining the
toll calls
and reporting him to the president now
if i may go a step further also
he asked me to do this
at after seven o'clock one night and i
told him that'd be
the wrong thing to do a terrible thing
to do it would lead to
allegations concerning the fbi being a
gestapo waking people up and
particularly getting information from
the telephone company which would come
known later on and bring stigma to them
so
he came back on the phone and he said
who do you think is your
commander-in-chief and
i told him i said there's no doubt in my
mind but what you are but i'm trying to
save you from embarrassment and also the
fbi from embarrassment and he said all
right but you better have in the morning
and
i did have it the next morning
intel pro what is that one tel pro is a
counterintelligence program
it was used widely against the ku klux
klan it was used widely against the
communist party
it was successful but
we made mistakes in that program and we
particularly made mistakes by letting
one of our assistant directors who was
under my supervision
and therefore i must bear some
responsibility also
but he operated many times without the
authority or the knowledge of mr hoover
clyde tolson and me and as a result we
made mistakes in that regard
william sullivan william sullivan
william c sullivan yes what year did he
die
i believe it was 19
73 or 4 1974 i believe
he died in a hunting accident he was
shot by the son of his chief of police
who thought that
he heard a deer walking along a roadway
uh in the forest are there still people
this day that suspect that that wasn't
the case i mean that was a controversy
at the time who shot william solomon the
facts are so clear that i've heard
nothing indicating that
it was a conspiracy but
sometimes the american public is very
gullible
and just like the john f kennedy case
the martin luther king assassination
case the uh
the bobby kennedy case the assassination
there
lee harvey oswald jack ruby
thousands people have made a living
out of uh raising conspiracies
concerning those cases and yet the facts
stand out in a stark
manner
very factual the evidence is
overwhelming about who killed who and
how did it happen and so on but still
you have
people among the american public who
will believe these wild and woolly
conspiracies but you always come back
full circle to the fact that the lee
harvey oswald in the kennedy case james
earl ray and the king case and sirhan
bashara sirhan
in the bobby kennedy case and you also
come back somewhat full circle from the
fact that there's a common denominator
here
each man if you'll examine his
background
wanted to go down into posterity by
committing the worst atrocity he could
find in order to well to go down in
history and to be remembered by the
american public they were loners they
wanted attention
and they got it
this is mixing apples and oranges but
the co intel program pro
program and martin luther king
and
j edgar hoover and communists now i'm
lumping all that together because you
have a whole chapter about king versus
hoover yes
let me just ask you a
general question did was there a
communist influence in your opinion
with martin luther king
i felt that the two individuals whom i
mentioned the book
the new york attorney by the name of
stanley levison who was a member of the
national committee of the communist
party and a fellow by emile lodell who
was hired by levison jack o'dell jack
o'dell and who worked with the
national the southern conference
leadership group
at leveson's instructions
who had the history of being a member of
the communist party
that raised the taint
of possible association with dr king or
at least influence on dr king now
the big allegation today here again is
the fact that we harass dr king
or hoover harass dr king
by placing a wiretap on him
wiretap was ordered by
attorney general robert f kennedy burke
marshall who was head of the the
assistant attorney general in charge of
the civil rights division at that
particular time stated that the wiretap
was placed because bobby kennedy didn't
know what else to do
dr king had been warned by president
kennedy in the rose garden about
association with leveson
and association with odell
uh burke marshall had talked to him
bobby kennedy had talked to him
but dr king
uh knew that
while he knew the facts involved there
obviously felt that he needed these men
or disbelieved the allegations
concerning their communist connections
because he kept them on regardless now
dr king himself was not i have never
seen anything
that dr king himself was a member of the
communist party
i feel that in my own opinion that dr
king was somewhat naive politically
or else he needed these men to the
extent that he kept them on
a news conference
that was held with sarah mcclendon
who is still
active in this town
and miriam ottenberg and about 18 women
yes kicked off a public
dispute between martin luther king and
uh j edgar hoover and what was that all
about how'd that happen
brian you know probably better than i do
the uh
influence of women in the journalistic
field in washington d.c at the present
time
the national press club had refused to
admit women
to his membership
they considered they they
brought considerable pressure on the
national press club until finally
you know women were admitted but they
formed at that particular time
the
national press club group of women an
organization
and miriam ottenberg of the evening star
sarah mcclendon and other notable women
reporters were on that uh and writers
were in that group
they had tried every way in the world
again a meeting with j edgar hoover
and he had turned them down until
finally he couldn't turn him down
anymore he had to allow these women to
see him
and to allow them to question him
but we've worked for several days
working out what he was going to say
facts figures fugitives recall fugitives
caught
automobiles recovered et cetera et
cetera but they were bored
they didn't like those statistics they
could have gotten those in writing from
the annual report or any other source
who was testimony before congress
so
who were sensing
that they were bored i decided to uh
to give them some startling information
before you do that how often did j edgar
hoover ever meet with reporters
this was the first time and also the
last time as far as i know really ever
yes he met with individual female
reporters from time to time and
individual male reporters and individual
male reporters but not uh
this was the first and only time that i
know that he met with him
and you quote him saying at this point
in the news conference when he thought
they were bored quote it is my opinion
dr martin luther king is the most
notorious liar in the country
that's correct he did say that and i
passed him a note
i was startled bob wick who was with me
at the time inspector
assistant director wig
was with me at the time a man that
reported to me and was one of the
i think best assistant directors we've
had and a very good man
but he rolled his eyes and he looked at
me and i looked a little startled and i
passed uh director hoover a note saying
don't you want to keep this off the
record
and he took the note and he balled it up
and
and threw in the trash i passed him
another note later on saying
don't you think the remarks concerning
king should not leave this room he threw
that away
the third time i passed him a note
towards the conclusion of the press
interview
he looked at me and he said i know he
told the women he said
delos just told me to keep the remarks
concerning dr king off the record he
said i refuse to do so you may print
them as i have given them to you well
the women left the room like a roof was
falling in they couldn't wait to get the
telephones and that started the feud all
over with dr king it quieted down
considerably
but then it started up again as a result
of that and it was a public relations
fiasco what was the dispute over i mean
mr hoover you say was mad about
something that
martin luther king had said you're right
brian when
dr king went to albany georgia
he was going to
have a campaign there
insofar as integration was concerned the
admittance of blackstone restaurants et
cetera et cetera
but he expected violence and violence of
course gives out with a lot of publicity
causes a lot of publicity
but the chief of police that particular
time at albany was chief laurie
pritchett
and pritchett was a very experienced law
enforcement officer he was a
i think a very civic minded man
and he met dr king with kindness with
the courage
he did not use dogs or fire hoses as
the chief of police in birmingham
alabama did
and to the contrary pritchett met him
with every kindness in the world there
was no publicity
dr king did not get funds to amount to
anything in albany
and as a result he made the press
release
indicating that
i presume
to to get into uh to get publicity uh he
made a press release indicating that
agents of the fbi
were seen in the company of police
officers
and of the agents in albany georgia
all of them were born reared
and educated in the in the south and as
a result
uh the afro-american or the black in
albany georgia cannot get a fair shake
in civil rights investigations
well hoover was infuriated and properly
so because he knew that whether an agent
was born in the north or the south
they still
gave equal treatment in so far as uh
investigation of civil rights matters
are concerned
but
to finish it to answer your question if
i
may uh
hoover immediately ordered a survey of
agents in the south
uh and particularly in albany georgia he
found that four of the five agents
assigned to albany that dr king had seen
were born reared educated and raised in
the north
and he also ordered a survey of all
civil rights investigation over a
10-year period
and he found none that had been where
the agents had been derelict
or whether the africa where
afro-americans had been shortchanged
in those investigations you see people
don't understand even today
that an fbi agent can go out and
investigate a particular matter
within the jurisdiction of the bureau
but that the results of that
investigation must be submitted to the
department of justice to determine
whether or not prosecution shall ensue
shall happen so as a result
uh if the invest fbi investigates
and the matter is referred to the
department of demand the department
turns it down
insofar as possible indictments or
prosecution is concerned
people blame the fbi for not carrying
through on it the fbi is an
investigative agency not a prosecutive
agency and it never shall be it should
be how much was martin luther king
followed and bugged and taped
as a result of attorney general
kennedy's
ordering the wiretap and the wiretap put
on dr king
that was used
i don't know the full length of time it
was used
the wiretap came about
on
as a result of approval given by
previous attorneys general
and i don't know how long that was on
but
it was a determination to be made by the
department of justice as to whether or
not we had sufficient information
to indicate communist influence on dr
king you say that you put a bug in his
hotel rooms and his sexual exploits were
recorded and tapes were passed on how
did how was the tape of all that passed
on to his wife
that was done by william c sullivan
an assistant director who followed the
sullivan in his office
found proof of that later on
and found out the sullivan without
approval from me from clyde tolson from
hoover
uh
had
an employee
on his staff uh take the tape
along with the letter which was composed
and sent it to coretta king mrs kane
uh hoover didn't know about that hoover
had no knowledge whatsoever of that what
was on the tape sullivan did that
strictly on his own
it concerned uh sexual escapades which
occurred here in the hotel in washington
d.c
and sullivan had no authority to do that
and no right to do and it shouldn't have
been done
it was a
a sickening act on his part you say that
bobby kennedy liked listening to these
tapes
bobby kennedy didn't uh i didn't say
that bobby kennedy liked listening to
the king tapes i said bobby kennedy
enjoyed listening both in in chicago and
new york
to uh wiretap some our big apartment
microphone
on members of the uh mafia uh la cosa
nostra or the mob or what have you
and he did an ins and instances one time
with
quite a number of agents around him in
new york with 17 agents around him and
the question was asked at that
particular time
by one of kennedy's men isn't this
illegal
and he said yes all matters all of these
particular matters are illegal
but he also complained about the fact
that we should get new equipment rather
than using
the equipment that produced a wiretap of
the microphone that he heard the
microphone tapes
because he said that they were a little
uh
they had static on them and therefore we
obviously needed new equipment
all the people you worked around and the
presidents you served and attorneys
general and all that who is the most
principled person
i like herbert brownell considerably as
an attorney general during the
eisenhower years yes
and bill rogers i thought was
he was a very good attorney general to
get along with
john mitchell was a no-nonsense man he
was later involved in the
watergate matter and went to prison as a
result of it
but john mitchell while he was in office
was very friendly he was as i say a
no-nonsense man
he believing upholding a letter of the
law and he was very easy to cooperate
with
how would you characterize your own
attitude about politicians in general
i think there's a certain
tenor which is increasing today in the
united states that in order to be in
politics you also have to be
hypocritical to a great extent
you have to
practice yourself what you feel the
the tenor of the times is among the
people who are going to be giving you
the votes and therefore you act
accordingly whether you believe in or
not
i think we need to get back more to
real principles
and politicians to
practice what they really believe in
rather than what
majority believes in perhaps or what
people believe in now
what i personally feel about it that's
that's my opinion that but you tell
stories about old-timers that
aren't
terribly uh positive i mean what about
esther's kiefer
yes keith olber was
scared that he was uh very apprehensible
the fact he was going to be killed
uh and i'm a drinker and a womanizer
exactly
that was our opinion and uh
but
he wanted to be protected he wanted an
investigation to find out whether or not
there was a bomb underneath his house in
tennessee and and we refused to do it
it wasn't our authority to do things
like that not within our jurisdiction
uh yes i think they're very fine
senators and verifying congressmen
in some respects but i think others
are hypocritical to a great extent
how did you get into this in the first
place in the fbi yeah where were you at
the time i was a student in law school
at stetson university in deland florida
when i heard that uh the eight nazi
saboteurs had been
arrested by the fbi within a 72-hour
period and i thought
rather than
becoming a lawyer and getting out in
private practice or
going into the service that particular
time like most of my classmates were
going
that i would go into the fbi and i
researched the matter researched the
organ of facts about the organization
and thought it was a good hard-hitting
striking organization and it proved to
be just that now
after a year and a half in there i
left the fbi
let me be very honest about it
hoover indicated that all agents under
24 years of age
uh they had no dependents
should have their one eight
uh a bigger part in their their uh
deferred status taken away problem
i knew that mine was going to be taken
away so i i joined the navy
i stayed in there for uh
not quite two years and i came back to
the fbi after that
i wanted brian i wanted to be
i wanted combat duty and i applied for
it accordingly
but i was they found that the navy found
out that i had played college football
i've been an fbi agent i'd been to law
school so i was transferred to norman
oklahoma and played football
and taught athletics there for a long
time how were you able to bring up this
size of a family on an fbi man's salary
it was tough not easy
my wife is a marvelous
cook she is a marvelous uh
uh handler uh the handler of uh
of the family and and uh she deserves
far more praise than i do
in uh and rearing the family
can your kids go on to be fbi agents no
they haven't but i have three sons that
are lawyers ones with disney world in
orlando florida another is with the with
velasquez incorporated as assistant
general counsel
in michigan and the third one is uh head
of the town's legal services in hilton
head island south carolina
your book is endorsed by sam devine
former congressman and fbi agent
jack anderson syndicated columnist
and paul harvey different personalities
was that your idea yes
i've known them all very well
what was mr anderson's relationship with
mr hoover
uh jack anderson i used to have lunch
together quite frequently and he would
gripe about drew pearson and
occasionally i would grab it by j edgar
hoover and the strict discipline
it was all on a friendship basis
mr hoover did not like jack anderson
because
well if i may put it crudely
he had
mr hoover on one occasion referred to
jack anderson after anderson had printed
a column about uber accepting favors
from richardson and murchison in texas
and mr hoover was very infuriated about
it and at women's
press club cocktail party which he went
to not an interview
but her particular social matter
the women asked him what he about his
opinion concerning
jack anderson and he said i think he's a
garbage picking so-and-so
jack didn't like that so he printed
further he had hoover's garbage checked
and found out that he drank jack daniels
he loved peppermint ice cream and so on
nothing derogatory
but
jack anderson always played very square
with me and reported facts properly
when he called me concerning press
matters and
i enjoyed dealing with him where was
this picture taken in what year
j edgar hoover
i believe that was taken and
in 1968 or nine before i left in 1970
cartha d deke deloach
author of hoover's fbi the inside story
by hoover's trusted lieutenant thanks
for your time thank you it's a privilege
to be on your show brian